all right speaking of Love though people
love their iPhones and we begin this
hour with a rare conversation with
Apple's CEO Tim Cook Apple the world's
most valuable company is rolling out new
features designed to save lives they
include technology that can detect when
you are your Apple device are in a car
crash another new feature lets you send
an emergency SOS message when there is
no Wi-Fi or cellular data using a
satellite and we can announce right here
on CBS mornings that the new satellite
service launches later today here in the
U.S and in Canada
during our recent visit to Apple Silicon
Valley campus we got an exclusive look
at the satellite service and talked to
Tim Cook about everything from the
future of Apple to its relationship with
Twitter
we're going to make some history
together today
the introduction of Apple's iPhone
helped push smartphone adoption to the
masses and in the years since its 2007
debut
the company has continued to refine its
Flagship handset while developing
products like watches and tablets is
this a tech company or a health and
wellness brand
well that's a good question Tim Cook is
Apple's CEO he's been with the tech
giant since the late 90s and succeeded
Steve Jobs as the leader of the brand in
2011. we're a company that wants to
enrich people's lives with other
products yeah when we ship the watch
initially we did so thinking about it
from a wellness point of view I started
getting notes about people that found
out that they had heart issues that they
didn't know about and the next thing we
did was put an ECG out and so we just
had kept pulling the string and we keep
asking ourselves how can we help iPhone
14 pro will be able to communicate with
satellites starting today iPhone 14
users in the US and Canada will be able
to text via satellite with Emergency
Services when cellular and Wi-Fi
coverage isn't available just make sure
you have a clear view of the sky into
Horizon and the system will guide you
through a number of intuitive screen
swipes moves and Taps is that a little
satellite up there that is a little
satellite up there Cayenne drense is
that people's VP of iPhone marketing and
it disconnected and it just connected so
what it's doing now it is sending the
answers to the questions that I just put
in it sends my location information
including my elevation it sends my
medical ID if I've set that up even my
battery level on the phone the small
white spaces represent gaps in cellular
service Apple's emergency SOS via
satellite is designed to help fill those
gaps I'm a hiker and so I'm frequently
out in places where there is no service
and you don't want there to be polls out
there either because you kind of are
getting away it's getting the witnesses
of it uh frankly and but now to have the
the ability to contact in the event of
an emergency is huge it really is you
know if you go to National Parks the
national parks are largely not covered
by cellular service and so this happens
to people all the time and it feels so
great to be able to talk to a satellite
100 of miles away traveling at fifteen
thousand miles an hour in addition to
the emergency SOS feature commencing
tests Apple's latest iPhone and watch
line are designed to detect severe car
crashes and if needed automatically dial
9-1-1 for help we crash a ton of cars we
put thousands of devices more
importantly thousands of iPhones and
apple watches into these cars into
wherever people would put their phones
in watches while driving Ron Huang is a
senior member of Apple's sensing and
connectivity division he says Apple
spent years studying vehicle impacts we
collected a lot of High Fidelity data to
really from the device's Vantage Point
what a crash looks like when it comes to
Apple as it acquires more information
tries to create more products to make
this seamless relationship between its
users and the products even better you
know where is too far because you said
that privacy is a fundamental human
right that's right and we deeply believe
that and so things even like crash
detection which we've talked about all
of that information is held on your
device right because we see it as your
information we're not sucking that
information up into the cloud to make
decisions off of it and so we believe in
getting the very bare minimum level of
information that we need to provide
somebody a service
and we see privacy as this
uh issue that is the issue of the
century
cook has watched the company gain
trillions of dollars in market value
since he took the him and while Apple
Remains the world's most valuable
company it isn't spared from current
economic conditions there's been reports
that Apple has frozen hiring in certain
areas where do you see apple as it tries
to navigate this unpredictable economic
future so what we're doing as a
consequence of being in this period is
we're being very deliberate on our
hiring that means we're continuing to
hire but not everywhere in the company
are we hiring we believe strongly in
investing for the long term and we don't
believe you can save your way to
Prosperity we think you invest your way
to it cook wants to focus on his
employees and his company but there are
other headlines coming out of Silicon
Valley that are hard to ignore
especially when your product hosts apps
like Twitter Twitter has been the
headlines I don't want to ask you about
anybody else but I'd be remiss if I
didn't is there anything that Twitter
could evolve or devolve into where it
would cause you to discontinue that
relationship or remove them from the you
know they say that they're going to
continue to moderate and so I I think
that uh you know I I count on them to do
that and because I don't think anybody
really wants hate speech on their
platform and so I'm counting on them to
continue to do that I would love to ask
you about retirement but I don't want to
do that I've learned my lesson with Tom
Brady we just don't know but what's next
for Tim Cook oh I don't know I I look at
this company and I it's a privilege of a
lifetime to be here and I get to work
with people I really love to work with
and spend time with them and so there's
a lot of joy in my life because of apple
and it's really hard to Envision life
without Apple